I first I first started thinking about
this I I became a father at the ripe old
age of 44 and various sort of historical
contingencies let's call them so sort of
it that my my nation's son would be
sharing his house with two senescent
canines there was there was Nina an
endearing utterly endearing but but um
you know occasionally ferocious when
something annoyed a German Shepherd
Malamute makes and Tess who was a what
she was a princess Tess was but but she
also had a she was a wolf dog mix and
she you know she was lovely but she she
did have some sort of fairly highly
developed predatory instincts and so you
know I was little worried about how the
sort of co-sharing arrangements were
going to were going to work but um as it
turned out III needn't have worried
thank you thank you Justin because I
sort of alternately shocked dumbfounded
you know amazed by the kind of kindness
and patience and toleration that they
they exhibited towards my my son so you
know this sort of crawled on kicked need
elbow dribbled on you know this was all
shrugged off you know the fingers in the
eye they received on almost daily basis
we just shrugged off with almost
zen-like calm you know in many ways they
weren't they were they were better
parents than I was my son so so much
just squeaked in the middle of my night
then I'd have to cold noses pressed up
against my face you know get up you're
negligent parent Arush yes you're right
your child needs you you know so what
these are the these these things
kindness patience toleration I'm
describing the dogs in in in moral terms
they're all forms of what we might call
concern yep concern for the welfare of
my son
so this started a sort of puzzle because
at least kicked off a sort of chain of
thought which went something like this
everything I've been told in my sort of
philosophical training that convinced me
that animals couldn't be moral because
if there's one thing that philosophers
and scientists almost almost without
exception agree on it's sort of human
moral exceptionalism humans and only
humans are moral creatures but on the
other hand I've come to think of my my
dogs is exerting it's exhibiting sorry
moral characteristics at least of some
some sort and so I was you know
gratified to learn that I wasn't just
insane you know that that various
scientists had also started some sign
it's not many still but some had started
to at least contemplate the the
possibility that other animals animals
other than human beings could be could
be moral creatures the the primatologist
France Duvall argued argued in a book
called primates and philosophers that
but animals were at least proto moral
they may not be moral in the same sense
that human beings are but they they have
some of the sort of fundamental building
blocks of morality in their in their
behavior
and this actually was was was Darwin's
Darwin's view in the in the Descent of
Man animals are almost kind of quasi
moral they're not moral in the same way
that we are but they they are sort of
proto moral and there's a cognitive
ethology just called mark became very
good friends with him actually and you
know he's been arguing for years that
animals can act morally so so this is
the sort of evidence they have in mind
people like France and and Mark when
when they when they make this claim take
elephants elephants provide sort of
great examples so we have we have
eleanor the matriarch of her
who was his dying basically she's
falling down and she can't she can't get
up so an unrelated female elfin called
grace from a different family of
elephants tries to help her and spends a
considerable amount of time trying to
push her back to her feet that uses a
head and legs and so on to try and get
grace to get Ellen of back to her feet
and this this is you know with this it's
successful for a while and it does
manage to stand up again but she's too
weak and she falls and and Grace's
efforts they're after or not successful
the next morning grace and another
elephant sir Maui show up and they try
the same thing they try to get out on
the back to her feet it doesn't work and
you know Ellen unfortunately dies a few
a few what an hour later actually so
this is the sort of this is one kind of
example because the sort of behavior of
of grace was seemed to go with with what
would normally be regarded as distress
behavior in elephants you know there's a
lot of shrieking and things like that so
um if if if that kind of grim tableau
was was was you know something that went
on between human beings I think we'd
have little little hesitation in saying
that well Grace's Grace's behavior if
grace is now a human let's suppose now
and as a human Grace's behavior it was
caused by you know something like
sympathy or concern for for Eleanor and
likewise the nave of Maui so the
question is is is is is Grace and my are
grace of Maui in this case acting
morally
here's another case witnessed by it by
by someone who studies elephants called
Joy's pool there's one elephant I have a
female elephant has a withered leg and
can't walk properly a male L from frog
from another rum I'm not sure what male
elephants what the collective noun is
actually females its family anyone know
what the collective for it I think it's
a pod I'm not sure but they're very
different behavior apparently you know
female fans hang out and they're all
kind of nice and male elephants sort of
you know get drunk and knock over
mailboxes and things like that you know
it's a very different social setup so so
so the male elephant charges the
crippled female elephant and and so on
and then another female child cases him
away and then sort of gently touches the
withers leg off of the female elephant
so again the question is well is this a
form of moral concern or take as the
switching from elephants to to Apes
anyone ever hear of vintage wah
when did you I was a gorilla female
lowland gorilla in in the Brookfield Zoo
in Illinois and one day a three-year-old
boy falls into their enclosures as they
tend to do you know and and this causes
you know as you might imagine there's a
fair amount of sort of concern and
hand-wringing and so on but vintage-y
the gorilla became famous when she she
picked up this boy sort of cradled him
in her arms for her for a while barked
warnings that any other gorillas that
might be tempted to to come too close
and eventually took him over to the the
access gate and handed him over to the
keeper so again the question is well is
this is this moral behavior and you know
there's this an array of panoply of like
examples of seemingly moral behavior in
in
in animals and this has actually been
known for for quite some time in 1959
Russell Church a psychologist
demonstrated that mice wouldn't push a
button which gave them food if doing so
caused one of their fellow mice to
receive an electric shock and later in
64 stat Stanley we're working and and
colleagues demonstrated that rhesus
monkeys exhibited the same sort of
behavior they wouldn't push a food lever
lever that would deposit food on the
dish if doing so shocked another another
monkey one what one monkey refused to
push this lever for twelve days even
though he must have been you know rather
rather peckish by then so so so the
question is well this seems to be on the
face of it you know a form of moral
concern is this a case of moral behavior
in animals surprisingly enough that the
sort of the biggest depository of
apparently moral behaviors in animals
can now be found on on youtube so if
essential sort of you know essential
study research Aid and YouTube is for
coming so here's my favorite um there
are two dogs on ER on a busy highway
it's equivalent of a motorway in in
Chile okay and one of the dogs is hit by
a car and the other dog you know a grave
risk to its own life weaves in and out
of the traffic and eventually manages to
pull the other dog off the road the
other dog actually survived and it turns
out they're not related in any way so so
again this seems to be an example of at
least apparently moral behavior so so so
the question is well what do we how do
we interpret this sort of sort of
evidence did you know that the institute
of arson ideas also has a podcast
philosophy for our times brings you the
biggest ideas from the leading thinkers
around the world every week search for
philosophy for our times and subscribe
today on your favorite part
platform SoundCloud or iTunes to make
sure you never miss an episode